that's robert irwin displaying some
quick reflexes long story short it's the
first time i've ever actually had to
completely
ditch the food run jump over a fence
during the season finale of crikey it's
thorough wins robert had a close call at
his family's australia zoo the son of
the crocodile hunter himself the late
steve irwin the 18 year old prove he's
all about the family business
now casper's going to be the new star of
the midday croc show before casper makes
his debut in the crocker scene we need
to do a bit of a test just to make sure
that he's settling in nicely to this new
enclosure to no one's surprise robert
volunteered to hop into the crock pin
why don't we just go straight down the
back first of all that's going to entail
someone jumping in
with casper now we want to see a nice
big reaction out of him that's how we
know he's happy
well be careful what you wish for robert
he did not care about the food he was
just trying to figure out how to eat me
the erwins recently chatted with e.t
robert reflected on the close encounter
and opened up about how it's all part of
carrying on his father's legacy a quick
follow-up that that was that scary for
you though what was that like it's
you're making it sound like it's your
first serious brush it was definitely
definitely scary i think it's it's um
one of those things anytime you're in
feeding a crocodile i think it's it'd be
it'd be crazy not to be to be very
nervous it's a a really exciting
adrenaline rush and for me crocodiles
have have been for a while now really my
specialty and and what i love to do more
than anything is to work with these
incredible animals and i think it really
is because of dad he instilled that
passion and here at australia zoo we
work with our crocs like nowhere else on
the planet we're able to get in there
not just you know chuck a piece of food
to them but really replicate that
natural behavior they get to strike out
of the water they think that they're
hunting and striking just as they would
in the wild it's great for them mentally
and physically and of course to teach
everyone about them in here
you got me cornered here mate it's a
funny thing when you work with crocs
long enough you start to see
just that look in their eyes and change
in body demeanor and it's one of those
instances where if you don't time it
just right and get out of his way that's
it and with such a powerful animal like
that it's a it's a pretty hectic thing
[Music]